and because Maurice is going to tell us
some things about them well we have a
special guest with us P Samson from
Nigeria here to play in the Eco wash
tournament and she's been playing some
great blitz chess as well peace welcome
to the show first of all tell us what
it's like to be here in Abidjan with all
these great chest action and players
well when I was told I was part of those
community our vision and I was like come
on dude when I looked at indecision and
so that's people like Kyle saying the
same icon I was like wow I'm coming I'm
flying down there right away
magnus carlsen did you ever imagine you
would have had a chance to meet him
watch him play I imagined you know
everything what's it like being in the
Hall because you get to yeah after your
games you came and you're in the hall
and you're seeing him sit there live and
in the flesh
oh wow this is wonderful like a dream
come true
what does this ornament mean for this
West African region to have the elite
players of chess does it inspire
motivate of course it's really inspiring
really inspiring personally her million
spent like God's incidentally make some
moves I'm like wow doesn't a wrong move
and I didn't we did in one all right
what you also played and tournament
yourself
tell us about how your tournament way
that how your team did in the event oh
my team did great
same Nigeria beam and we came second to
Nigeria it came first so still Nigeria
we all came from Nigeria seems to
dominate what what's happening in
Nigeria that you guys are playing so
well we have lots of tournaments we get
some practices of gossipy ourselves and
it's improved our chess now we do better
you played in the blitz as well today we
have one Graham Jorgensen who obviously
helps us with the grant and Chester was
on the board there did you beat him
today
but nobody was choking like you might
get invited back if you keep beating on
the official but you're not worried
about that I know you're gonna be going
home back to Nigeria soon still you can
you feel the dream you pinch yourself
you have to leave such a great event
yeah I wish I mean Libra I have to and
yeah living also so I have to leave soon
coming back next year possibly possibly
only if that invites aid then I like the
concept
absolutely well we love having you here
thank you very much for joining us P
Sampson one of the contingents from
Nigeria showing